j'avais écrit la chanson daniel
balavoine vous l'avez écrit à quelle
occasion je crois que c'est un petit peu
au moment du film kramer contre kramer
qui a fait aussi mais ça aussi tout à
l'heure aux candidats une jeune fille
qui a parlé encore justement de cette
chanson n'est pas d'en faire plaisir je
crois que les des chansons ça sert aussi
à ça ça sert à un artiste qui n'est pas
quelque chose qui voudraient
éventuellement l'être ou qui veut faire
savoir des choses de pouvoir s'inventer
des personnages et d'en parler au nom de
ceux qui ne peuvent pas je veux dire
qu'on n'est pas des porte paroles il
faut pas non plus que ça dégénérant en
paroles d'évangile dire quand j'ai écrit
cette chanson simplement parce que deux
de mes amis ont vécu ce problème et qui
se trouve que 1,1 discrètement
indirectement par les sapins
indirectement med med m'a dit peut-être
que je pourrai faire une chanson sur le
même physique kramer contre kramer je ne
savait pas à ce moment là que lui même
avait ses problèmes et en fait j'ai
appris après qui s'était servi de cette
chanson pour envoyer le texte à sa femme
bon mais oui ça arranger les choses
une fois que ces dérangé c'est des fois
ça sert comment souvent un peu plus tard
enfin je me fais dire si ça a pu
arranger les choses c'est tant mieux
cher que ce qui est intéressant la danse
pour moi c'est que cette chanson est une
chanson que je ne voulais pas faire au
départ qui lorsque je les ai écrites est
une chanson qui me déplaisait parce que
je la trouvais un peu je le dis
maintenant sont un petit peu comme on
dit démagogique ses rejetons que toutes
les chansons et tous les sujets qu'ils
traitent directement des enfants sont
des choses extrêmement délicate a touché
et puis jusqu'au jour où en revenant ce
serait un peu ce que vient de dire
madame cyr un jour en revenant de
toulouse où j'étais allé faire des
émissions j'ai rencontré monsieur qui
doit voir 45 ou 50 ans et des cheveux
grisonnants très aimable la cravate
attaché-case ou donc pas censé être
normalement concernés par ce que je fais
dans ma tête à moi je me fais un petit
peu de fausses idées des fois
heureusement pour moi qui ait des gens
cet âge là qui m'aime bien et qui est
venu carrément aéroports le remercie de
re a fait cette chanson parce qu'il est
en train de vivre ce problème et qu'il
avait aucun moyen de l'exprimer où que
se soigne à la radio ni à la télé et que
le fait que que moi je le fasse et passe
à lui rendait service moralement je
trouve ça bien je dis il faut pas non
plus tout d'un coup des lissiers tout ça
il faut pas dramatiser je te savais que
beaucoup perd actuellement vivre ce
drame et se bat actuellement pour eux
aussi s'occuper de leur enfant en cas de
jeu pas montré trop là dedans
débat tellement longue je trouve c'est
quelque chose de monstrueux de dire
qu'on se bat qu'on s'entre déchirent
pour des enfants nus que les enfants
deviennent un enjeu
les enfants sont pas des enjeux les
enfants sur des êtres humains et qu'on
leur foute un peu la paix je dirai
simplement une chose c'est que moi mes
parents je dis souvent que je pense pas
que ça les gêne se sont séparés quand
moi j'étais très jeune j'ai quatre trois
frères et de soeurs bon et il se trouve
que si mes parents étaient restés unis
c'était bien entendu je serais peut-être
pas là aujourd'hui en train d'en parler
avec vous j'aurais peut-être été comme
je voulais le faire un moment donné un
étudiant brillant ou pas brillant en
droit ou en sciences politiques ou des
choses comme ça et en fait j'aurais raté
ma vie
fierté si ça s'trouve je dois je dois la
réussite que j'ai même si elle est
momentanée on ne sait rien encore tu
dois en tout cas cette réussite que
j'aurais eu une seule fois dans ma vie
peut-être au fait que mes parents ont
vécu la vie qu'ils ont vécu et c'est il
faut pas dramatiser cdi des deux parents
ça de la souffrance des enfants qui ont
des parents séparés faire que les
enfants je dis pas qu'ils s'en foutent
un peu musique ça leur apporte d'autres
choses et ça rapporte une autre vie
[Musique]